we're on problem 119
is 2x minus 3y less than x squared 2x
minus 3y
less than
x squared
they ask us
all right let's see if we can figure it
out statement one two x minus three y is
equal to minus two
two x
minus
three y
is equal to
minus 2. so they're telling us that the
left-hand side of this original equation
is equal to -2 so now this question if
we take statement 1 into consideration
it boils down to
is -2 less than x squared
so first you might be saying oh i i
don't know i don't know what x is but
think about it can x be a negative
number at worst worst case x is zero
right that's the worst case if
x was anything else
x squared is going to be a positive
number right so we actually know just
from statement 1 that negative 2 has to
be less than x squared unless x was some
type of weird imaginary number or
something and i think that doesn't occur
on the gmat so statement one alone is
sufficient x squared is going to be at
least zero as probably an or some
positive number larger than zero
so statement one is sufficient
statement two
x is greater than two
and
y
is greater than
zero
and y is greater than zero
so let me just try to come up with two
contradictory cases using these
conditions to see let's say if x was and
they don't tell us that anything is an
integer here right
so if x was 2.1
x is equal to 2.1
and y is equal to
i don't know they say y is greater than
zero so let's say that y is equal to
point one
right let's see what happens here
so two times two point one you get 4.2
minus 3 times y so minus 0.3
is less than x squared so 20 is what
it's like four point
four point something so it's greater
than two
this is interesting
because i think it
right because if y is greater than zero
actually this is interesting so i
actually don't have to try examples out
because just let's just write the
equation down 2x minus 3
y is less than x squared
so if y is greater than 0 which they
tell us in statement 2
then the quantity on the left hand side
is always going to be 2x is always going
to be less than 2x right because this
will have some positive value it might
have a insignificantly small value why
we could make it .00001
but it's still going to have some
positive value so no matter what y we
choose as long as it's greater than 0 2x
minus 3y will be greater than 2x right
so we could say that
as long as
2x if 2x is less than x squared
for any x we pick
if 2x is less than x squared for any x
we pick then 2x minus 3y is definitely
going to be less than x squared why is
that because -3y is going to subtract
from the 2x because we know that y is
greater than 0.
so let me ask a question
is 2x
always going to be less than x squared
if x is greater than 2
sure i mean whatever
x is
it's going on the left-hand side it's
going to be 2 times you know
pick a random number 2 times
well x you know it could be 2.5 right
but on the other side on the right hand
side you're going to have 2.5 squared
so if you think about you're going to
have 2 times a number
that's always going to be less than that
number which happens to be larger than 2
squared right
the smallest possible is you know 2
times
2.000
1. you could you know make that in you
could make the a lot of zeros there but
i think you get the point that's still
going to be less than 2.001
squared
right because you only have a 2 here
instead of a 2.001
so actually statement 2 alone is
sufficient
hopefully that made sense you just have
to see oh if y is greater than 0 then
the 3y is definitely going to take away
from the 2x and then as long as x is
greater than 2 2x is always going to be
less than x squared and if that makes
sense to you then then you should
realize that statement 2 alone is
sufficient for this that was interesting
oh no sorry not statement either of them
alone were sufficient we did that in the
first one right statement one or
statement two independently are
sufficient to answer that question
120 a report consisting of 2600 words is
divided into 23 paragraphs so 2600
words and it has 23
paragraphs
a two paragraph preface is then added to
the report so two paragraph preface
is the average
number of words per paragraph for all 25
paragraphs
less than
less than 120. so this is interesting so
the average number of
see
words per paragraph for all 25
paragraphs less than 120.
so if we knew the total number of words
in the document we'd be set we would
just take the total words
total words
divided by the total paragraphs they
have now they have the 23 original plus
the two from the preface
and you have 25 and you do total
paragraphs and now it told you the
average words per paragraph now you we
don't know the total words because the
total is going to be equal to
the 2600 words in the body of the
document plus the words from the preface
i'll call that word
subpreface
all of that divided by 25 this is the
average and this is what we really have
to figure out to figure out if it's less
than 120
that's what they want to know
so statement number one
each paragraph of the preface
has more than a hundred words
so each
so
each paragraph of the preface has more
than a hundred words so i guess we could
say that the preface the words from the
preface
are greater than
two hundred
and that's another way of saying that is
that the total
total is going to be greater than twenty
eight hundred
now if the total is greater than 2800
what does that tell us about the total
divided by
excuse me
so then the total divided by 25 is going
to be greater than 2800 divided by 25.
it was 2800 divided by 25.
let's see 28
goes into 25 28 goes into 2800
125 30
1 times 25
25 50
12.
so it tells us that the average
the average is going to be greater than
112 so that doesn't help us if it told
us that the average was going to be
greater than 120 we would be done we
would say oh we have enough information
to answer the question and actually the
answer is no that the average is going
to be greater than 120.
but here this tells us the average grade
of 112 it could be 113 or it could be
121. so it doesn't answer our question
of whether the average is less than 120.
so statement one alone is not that
useful
statement number two
tells us
each paragraph of the preface has fewer
than 100 words
so the total preface
has less than
300 words
right they say each paragraph of the
preface and there's two of them has
fewer than 150 words so the total
preface
has less than 300 words so we could do
the same
logic the total
the total is going to be
so that means that the total
is going to be less than what
the total is going to be less than the
original
number of words plus the preface is
going to be less than
2600 plus 300 it's going to be less than
and then if you divide both sides by 25
to get the average
goes into 2900
really four more times
right
four more times
right that's right
so it's going to be
the average
is going to be less than let me make
sure i'm getting that right so 4
on a 25 goes into 2900
and we have 150
25 goes into 150 six times so we have
the average is less than 116.
so statement 2 alone is sufficient
statement 2 tells us that the average of
the words per paragraph is less than 116
which is definitely less than 120. so
statement 2 alone is sufficient and
statement 1 doesn't help us much and
i've run out of time see in the next
video